foreign
I want to play a game and by the way
this is one of one of the few people
that actually liked their commentary on
the Brendan Schaub stuff the tfatk
um can we figure out who Brian Collins
talking about in this you ready
all right so in this video we see the
wrinkle Brian Callan go on the
uninfluenced podcast and we know who
he's talking about he talks trash on his
best friend Brendan shop roll the damn
footage you know this is such a taboo
subject in a way right because you the
things you learn breeding dogs I am sure
have changed the way you look at human
beings everything right so I've learned
more about people from working with dogs
than anything but well is that why you
always sniff women's crotches when you
meet them like I'm trying to understand
how what do you learn well that's what
I'm saying he learned a lot about
[ __ ] people from dogs mostly white
women yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah good
point yeah I mean dogs have a lot of
things in common then with dogs than
anything but to but but and and we all
know my buddy and I were just talking
there are just some people that are just
like my joke is but it's true my I have
a buddy who's just he's just not dealing
with uh an advanced computer his model
is he's the iPhone one yeah like he just
sometimes you just catch him looking in
the distance with his mouth open I swear
to God it looks like he's like looking
for moths
whatever he's talking about
yeah it's just like yes and he
[Laughter]
[Music]
I guess they gave old Bri the kids chair
it's actually even funnier that he's
still trying to sound like an
intellectual while he's sitting in a
tiny chair lookie here not just in a
tiny chair
he's in a tiny chair with some sick ass
rims behind him okay so let's not
pretend like the rims behind him aren't
[ __ ] sick and he's also sitting
Indian style of course he's well it
looks small called crisscross applesauce
now
okay okay we don't want to you know get
Elizabeth Warren to be mad at us or
anything like that we're using
technology as an analogy of Baba's
cognitive capacity an iPhone one is far
too generous now a Commodore 64 that has
been thrown out of a fifth Story window
and rediscovered in a junkyard is much
more fitting Brennan job is more like a
Loosely wired light switch sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't
God he's the [ __ ] worst my Brendan
shop is just the worst it's the worst if
you push it to the right a little when
you flip it it has a higher chance of
working you leave it on go to the main
breaker and turn everything off come
back and it's still on you try to figure
out how it's still on after every
available source of power has been cut
off then you realize oh his father is
funding the whole thing and the fact
they gave Brian Callan the baby seat
wait wait wait wait wait wait
Brian Callan status funding the whole
thing is that what he's saying
yeah I don't know here's my thing okay
about this channel
this guy
he's good he's good at narrating he's
funny
but he stretches some things sometimes
man
he does stretch some facts you know and
and
um fills in some blanks that I don't
necessarily see sometimes so I don't
know if that's true or not because this
guy kind of mixes a little bit of
[ __ ] in there yeah I mean
yeah well what about this one here I got
one more one more there's this one this
one this one we could all agree on
Brenda not knowing what words mean okay
how's that that's actually a warning and
joining one from certain Acts or
practices a caveat against unfair
practices an explanation to prevent
misinterpretation a modifying or
cautionary detail to be considered when
evaluating interpreting or doing
something or as Brendan job would say
caveat let's check this video out you
can't wait okay here we go let's see if
he knows what the word means you ready
down you're like huh Miley Miley caveat
with that shoot pulled off and pop us
does the champion have what's the one
caveat here what's the one kind of
Achilles you heal with my well Champion
what is this is it a caveat or is there
an Achilles heel because they're
different two different things
completely different things by the way
experience yeah please please with the
fight thing the one caveat there I don't
think people are thinking of so they're
more vibrant way
um there's also caveat about it I don't
mean interrupt you okay uh you know hey
Frozen got any caveat back there I'm
starving bro do you have any Beluga
caveats back there it's my favorite kind
I'm sorry guys we're fresh out oh okay I
don't mean interrupt your little caveat
about each I don't mean to interrupt you
something Brandon has never meant pH
though so the one thing that's he talks
beer now the only caveat here it's the
all day bro he said bro like one or two
times but he's singing like caviar like
80 90 times caveat though the caveat
yeah the the biggest caveat he did say
caveat a lot Brandon there's the the
weird one off that tool no no and and I
did say this I want to caveat with this
when you you took much of I took which
one will never be beat but the the
caveat there is they asked the dad Julio
Chavez senior they said I need to run
with and he gives me entertainment and I
caveat with I don't wow he really it's
not that he's saying because look to be
fair you could probably cut from 100
interviews and make it seem like he says
that a lot this is one episode we're
counting in this one episode five times
let's bring the same outfit yeah believe
all this but going according to him now
this is my only caveat here it says it's
eight inches thick hard I Chevrolet
Silverado now caveat to being the most
unreliable bro it's a lot I will
remember how many Chevy Silverados are
how many Teslas there are mad that there
was you know that showed the abortions
my caveat to that is but that's her
story should they ignore all that yeah
that's her story they should close them
justice so
ah Mark Harley we got a surprise Mark
Carly in the corner yeah bgl appearance
big gay lion big gay lion bro I love him
he's like my favorite [ __ ] guy now
like more than more than anybody else uh
he's feeling actually
uh which it's funny because guys do
yourself a favor and search Mark Carly
we are like we are his algorithm now